alright guys bangbang coming to you live
from the new off-the-chain studio not
really we just moved the office around
but I'm here with Natalie thanks so much
for coming to do this sure thank you so
much for inviting me
you got your proper shirt on ready to go
absolutely I love your new office
ABC always be closing I like it alright
let's let's jump right in
you are not from the United States and
you've got an awesome story so you were
born in Russia Yeah right
and then eventually ended up in Bulgaria
kind of tell us how yeah we read in
Russia and then in Bulgaria yeah
absolutely so I was studying software
engineering in Russia and at the age of
19 I moved to Bulgaria
established my first engineering company
that's my how my entrepreneurial career
started I and for 15 years I was
building and constructing real estate in
Bulgaria and then I thought well
actually I want again to build software
and so knowing all the problems I've
experienced in real estate I relocated
myself to the US four years ago and this
is how the sort of prop is started
alright let's talk about school in
Russia okay what is that like I'm
assuming it's like school in most other
countries
solutely I think in America we have this
vision of like Russian kids going to
school and sitting there from 5:00 a.m.
to like 10:00 p.m. and just being told
learning off the podcast
wait but no what is it it's a great
point that recently we had one account
proppy
that we didn't pass the background check
with them because of my Russian
background they were very resistant to
give data to a Russian founded
funny clearly yeah all right so what so
what's cool like in Russia as you study
computer science yeah so it's an
international university of nature and
computer science close to Moscow and the
beauty of this university is that the
first two years you have to learn many
subjects including software engineering
even if your major like mine was
environmental scientists and then the
others were lawyers economists they had
to learn how to code Oh everyone learns
yeah the first two years everyone had to
learn how to code and I just loved it
that was my first experience with a
computer before that I never touched the
computer even though I had a dream to do
it and but this led me to actually
transition from the environmental
studies to coding engineering department
and I used to help all they liked those
artistic majors to code and then and do
their work the first year yeah that's
awesome
all right so you learned how to code and
you pretty much know hey I'm gonna go do
this instead of the environmental work
why go to Bulgaria our university was
international and it's already met in
air quotes why are you cool because the
only international students we had was
from other post communist country which
was Bulgarian group and so yeah I met my
now ex-husband in the university I
relocated myself to Bulgaria and yet so
this is how I ended up in Bulgaria so
most people know that uh I'm fond of
Bulgaria now now that a Paulina is in my
life and I've been to Bulgaria numerous
times we're in a we're in the country
were you in Sofia I used to live in
Sofia in Plovdiv in the on the Seacoast
right now our engineering team sits in
Sofia but before that I was constructing
resort
birds on the Seacoast so it wasn't a lot
of fun it's nice to know so what is that
like Maga how do you go from software
development to building resorts yeah so
my first company was in a small garage
and I was coding simple applications
primarily web application for small
businesses and some real estate
developers and then Bulgaria as you know
it's a new European Union country they
announced that they will join the
European Union so suddenly those British
investors were coming into Bulgaria to
acquire properties and build and I was
looking at the couple of those buildings
appearing on the Seacoast and I thought
okay it looks like it's a very
capital-intensive lucrative business so
I went to UK I went to Russia Latvia
talked to potential customers figure out
what they want and talked to my
engineers okay now we're gonna acquire
land do awesome renderings of future
buildings and sell them cross borders so
this what made me to transition our
engineering team to engineers that you
had yeah you would buy land yeah but you
would have the engineers create building
renderings just drawings of them based
on where the most beautiful
sophisticated rendering people were
buying those real set pieces cross
borders without coming and seeing even
the sides so the side was empty so you
would sell the land or you would sell
them on investing to build the property
like to build off the building sell
condos resort full of condos with like
spas restaurants and so on
so they would buy a future unit that I
would be and then you would build it
yeah and I would be lit within one or
two years and normally there would be
all very happy with execution that
everything is just like it was projected
and design for the pictures but
everything was tech driven like we had
our own CRM system we had programmers to
make sure we're having the tracking
system of our customer
and that was 2005 yeah and so one of the
theories I have is that Bulgarian real
estate is gonna make a resurgence if you
agree
well with the reason I decided to
relocate myself from Bulgaria is
actually we my company was able to drive
all that interest to Bulgaria from
Russia Latvia so UK was interested there
anyway
you know they're they love real estate
globally but then 2009 and 10 the
interest started to decline so there is
there is no more such an interest from
foreign investors not only because there
is a decline of those international home
buyers but also the economic situation
the political is is really depressing
there so yeah as soon as there is no
such an influence from direct foreign
investment the local community also
stopped investing in real estate and
it's very affordable so yeah I would
agree that the real estate industry they
won't see any more
oh you think they won't see any more
interest no all right here's my theory
ready tell me yeah
so before Instagram nobody really knew
about Iceland yeah right and then all of
a sudden some people go and they take a
picture and Iceland and they put on
Instagram oh my god looks so beautiful
yeah and now Iceland's popping off
everyone loves Iceland yeah and there's
a bunch of these places around the world
where that's happened Bulgaria is a
place that a lot of people don't know
about they couldn't find it on a map you
know etc but they have the sea they've
got the mountains etc at some point over
the next five years my guess is that
people are gonna quote unquote discover
Bulgaria yeah
and then they're gonna all start going
there and it's like this whole thing so
this one I did in 2005 yeah I actually
opened the eyes of Russians which is
huge population
I opened their eyes to Bulgaria I
invited TV shows their reporters
influencers like yourself
so what my
happen I'm not a Russian influencer yeah
but what may happen now is an American
influencer will drive an American
interest to Bulgaria and maybe we will
see a new wave in Bulgaria to be
discovered by Americans yeah I think I
think it's gonna happen
yes all right so how much did a condo
cost at one of these results supper
table $50,000 $50,000 for a condo and
that was in 2005 right now you can buy
property for $50,000 with one bedroom
okay so now it's 50,000 TV I know it's
even quite cheaper than back then for
example I could sell a property in 2007
for $30,000 next year it would be 90 so
3x Wow
we did that with my property that's
pretty crazy yeah sounds like some
crypto investments absolutely it was
that type of a market and we were part
of the creation of it because it's a
beautiful country it's really beautiful
country with the Seacoast mountains the
talent the food everything is natural
organic also it could become sofy is
becoming a technical hub there are many
talented oh there's a bunch of places
he was Packard and the engineers they
are very talented and very disciplined
and they work hard 24/7
yeah all right so how do you go from
building the resorts to running a real
estate technology company yeah so I've
met many high net-worth individuals
acquiring properties in Bulgaria Dubai
UK and they all had this stress like
okay I want to buy property in London
and also I want to buy property in
Silicon Valley but the process is
different and I'm not sure if I will be
fooled so we saw this pain and it just I
got very very excited like hey we have
the opportunity here a huge opportunity
to automate the process
and we know how to make it
internationally so this how I came here
for one real estate conference for the
first time in America made this visa I
those times it was easy and yeah I came
here and the American real estate
community was very welcoming and saying
you have to do it here
yep so this is how I transition into
property got it and then that's when you
moved to the US four years ago yeah what
was the first city went to in America
San Francisco was your initial
impression uh you would be surprised it
was very very good somehow I missed all
the homeless part and all the disasters
I don't know how but for the first week
I kind of didn't see that ah and I love
the city I love the community every
single meeting I would go to in San
Francisco or in the Bay Area in the
peninsula all people are so welcoming to
newcomers they would ask how can we help
you can we make an introduction you need
to meet this person or that person so
that was a big changing environment for
me because before that I considered to
move to Dubai or Monaco or London those
are all horrible places very bad one
Dubai or Monaco oh my god okay you
choose San Francisco right and you knew
that you were gonna go try to solve this
problem but had you already started
proper yet or a you know resources about
the proper calm domain so I knew that I
want to build a global listing something
like Zillow but global with an ability
to talk my properties with a couple of
clicks obviously in order to to make
this process with a couple of clicks I
knew that I will need hundreds of
millions of dollars to make it as a
technological infrastructure so it just
started as an infrastructure like a
listing platform very simple and then I
started to to go around and meet many
many engineers who can solve
cross-border payments who can solve
paperwork and process and this is when I
got to know walked in got it
and so when you first started you didn't
have any clue that block chain or crypto
would be a part of the business now
quickly figured that out yeah okay so
tell us what exactly is probably doing
today
yeah probably today probably is the only
solution that is dedicated to automate
the entire home buying process the
closing process from the offer to
recording and the infrastructure level
is powered by smart contracts but on the
front and it's all easy to understand
for the home buyer step-by-step wizard
how to acquire property got it and does
the same thing apply when you're selling
those resort condos I don't have to go
see the property yeah right back then
they weren't looking at them today I
don't need to see it because you guys
are doing what like like what
information are you providing me on the
platform and are you guys doing like two
due diligence for me to make sure that
the property it says you know it is what
it says or well actually we're on for
now our focus is a closing process which
means that you've made a decision and we
always recommend our customers to come
and see the property but there are many
cases like our first transactions were
all made remotely with not even like
seeing a property so yeah we're just
focusing on the closing process even
when I was constructing and selling
properties in Bulgaria and they're cheap
many of our customs like half of them
would not come and see the property but
we always like recommend them strongly
to see what they're buying and then
afterwards to to make the closing got it
and so today if I find a property that I
want to buy do I need to have that
property on prop a like it does it
always have to be listed or I can talk
to the seller and say hey let's go ahead
and actually finalise this transaction
go on prop B create an account etc yeah
that's correct so you can find a
property you may have an agent and the
seller has an agent you tell to your
agent or the seller hey I'm ready to
close and I'd love to make it securely
and faster so let's use proppy
got it weirdest crypto coming the crypto
is coming on the smart contract level so
every single transaction step is powered
by smart contracts and our goal is to
eliminate all the manual work right now
there are 20 participants in every deal
at least that's minimum that has to do
manual verification and they input data
manually again and again and again so at
the point when the transaction is going
to recording there is a 20% rate of
mistakes from manual work so we're smart
contracts is coming the mission is that
we're doing a recording and ownership
transfer when software detects that the
payment wire transfer is executed and
the paperwork is executed this is why
every single step is handled by smart
contracts obviously it's not seen by the
users and for every single transaction
on our platform we have a talking that
unlocks the access to smart contracts
and do I need to buy the property in
crypto why do I pay in Bitcoin or
etherium or can I pay in dollars you can
do both you can do any currency we work
with 40 currencies fiat and all the
cryptocurrencies with the transactions
in Bitcoin ether it's the weirdest one
well not the weirdest but I love this
first transaction that we did 2017 the
first ever vlog chain and a power
transaction it what happened in ether
and the the buyer Michael Arrington no
Michaels great I know obviously and
that's to come and deals with us I'd say
man let's go yeah he's probably laughing
right now alright go ahead regards and
he said regardless well sitting here in
New York
it's Michael thing and yeah
so the the transaction was fabulous
in a sense that ether were transferred
to acquired property in Ukraine the
seller was in New York and smart
contract hold the funds till we get the
data that the paperwork is in place and
the signature with notaries approved and
not really approved the transaction on
the platform and then once the ownership
transfer happened which we had a data on
because of our governmental pilot the
smart contract rule released the funds
to the seller and to other parties
associated so it actually disrupted the
escrow function entirely so that was the
the the interesting part of the
transaction back then and what this is
what were aiming here in the US because
the majority of our deals here are
happening with wire transfers in dollars
it's like 99.9 percent i and we're
aiming to do the escrow function with
smart contract capability got it and so
in that first transaction Mike was
sitting in California the seller sitting
in New York but the properties in
Ukraine yeah that's correct it's pretty
complex but you guys all remotely
everything automated everything is
recorded and there are hedges on smart
contracts now you can go to ethers can
find the transaction see the movement of
money yeah that's pretty good
look out 20 years what does this grow
into right like where are you kind of
building towards yeah in 20 years we're
in vision property to be proper calm to
be an international ecommerce platform
where people are finding this property
the one tool to see and to buy they
would see then they would come and they
would have an experience like on Amazon
they go through a number of clicks and
they got the deed registered that right
there on the platform it's a very easy
way to transfer money you would put your
bank account if banks still exists in
the way they exist today
I and you would get your deed no words
no anxiety enjoyable process just like
we'll have our iPhones you would love
actually the process of home buying
because it's one of the most valuable
assets in our lives and do you do
fractional ownership or is it just I own
the property right now we had a number
of requests probably over a 1 billion
worth of requests one day we just said
and and counted them all off from
institutional players to tokenize real
estate so we have great expertise on
that but we don't do that but you don't
actually do it in the future maybe maybe
I mean once we have this marketplace up
and running for many many countries and
many buildings then obviously why not to
also offer hey invest $1,000 in this
building on that building or we're in
the resort yeah that makes sense
what do you seem globally in real
estates all right so I want to talk a
little bit about kind of a macro economy
and real estate for a second because
real estate similar to stocks
I just been going up yeah yeah keeps
going keeps going keeps going as we know
as students of history they can't go on
forever yeah and so there's likely to be
a market downturn at some point this is
happening already it's already explained
that Silicon Valley San Francisco market
are all solved for over 15 months really
yeah it's been soft some markets are
turning from seller market to buyer
market Dubai had a disaster in the last
two years after even announcing the acts
for 2020 and everyone was hoping that
the market will outperform but instead
it had at least 40 percent down right so
yeah you are right we're in this time
when the real estate market is softening
globally but at the same time there are
so many emerging markets where the
properties are underestimated like
Bulgaria
for example it's still a very very
affordable market and there are a number
of countries where they just figured how
to avoid fraud and make more efficient
title registry in fact seven nine
trillion dollars are unrecorded today
and it's dead capital in real estate
which will come to the to the economy
one day and obviously why you would
invest in the property in Silicon Valley
where the minimum check is two million
dollars where you can invest and two
hundred countries with a couple thousand
Tigranes yeah yeah exactly and you know
that they would appreciate for sure one
of the pieces that is interesting here
in the US so take New York for example I
read that 50% of the construction since
2015 of high-rise condos only 50% has
been sold so there's incredible amount
of supply that has come online that
there's just no demand for really I
didn't know about that and one of the
reasons why and what he's articles I was
reading is because foreign investment
has gone down okay so basically one of
the things that you got to think about
in terms of real estate for the people
listening you ever see notice is we sit
here and we say hey there's a lot of
people who want to buy real estate yeah
and we said let's go build real estate
right and to build high-rise condos yeah
that sounds a great idea
you know today in January 2020 let's say
yeah well it takes us a year to build it
or more right at once yeah but by the
time it gets done now all of a sudden
nobody wants to buy it yeah and so that
lag is actually pretty painful for real
estate developers and they're faced with
do they offload the inventory at below
market prices and try to recoup
something or do they hold it it's pretty
crazy to kind of see it happen well it's
not happening in the Bay Area for sure
and in San Francisco because there's
still a huge lack of housing of course
affordable housing
the man acid the original axe but in
terms of really development yeah this
what I was doing before I see the
interest in demand and then my company
would build a lot of inventory we sell
it but then we saw the the interest was
softening and we just stopped doing that
so in New York because for investors I
now had to pass through more kyc than I
used to it refers to Russian investors
Chinese investors and of course the the
majority of local communities they don't
want the outsiders that don't occupy
buildings so some of the cities like
Vancouver for example which we
introduced taxes for foreign investors
Oh interesting
yeah 15% tax on top of the property
price so that they encourage more the
local community to occupy those
buildings yeah it's pretty crazy how
real estate is such a like
well-established game right yeah it's
been around forever yeah
and people still make the same mistakes
people still make a lot of money off of
it yeah and there's the same cycles that
you would see in real estate in every
other market and it's kind of this you
know the more things change the more
they stay the same yeah definitely it's
a one of the most outdated industries
but it's worth 280 trillion dollars
globally so it's more Bitcoin yeah for
now yeah for now but the reality is that
the population is growing we will need
more inventory we will need more home so
we'll need more buildings and yes in
some local regions like here in New York
they might be we reach some highest
peaks in in price and this is now the
market has to adjust but in the majority
of places even though the market will
soften but we probably won't see any
crashes yeah it's um it's really
interesting to think through it right
because there's some counter to
of components to it but we'll see what
what's the general environment right now
as a founder in terms of fundraising and
kind of interesting crypto except like
you're doing this every day what are you
seeing there and how our investors
feeling about blockchain and crypto
companies yeah so as a founder obviously
I had to fundraise I have to build a
product I have to sell were thirty
people right now in the team and when we
talk to investors it's it's very
different now in comparison to 2018 in
2018 we probably was were bond bombarded
by emails from VCS every single week
from general is from top faces like yeah
the blockchain is cool and also you're
applying into a real industry and now it
seems like they all are afraid of the
blockchain in related investments but in
every single VC that is not focused on
the blockchain they always have this
young associate or a young partner that
is super excited about cryptocurrencies
and and blockchain and they always try
to push through the senior partner or
investor to find a way still to to be at
least to research or invest do you think
that that changes in the short term or
do you think that it feels like this is
gonna be how the sentiment will be among
venture capitalists for a while um it's
a hard question
yeah I'm not sure probably I yeah maybe
two three years it will be staying the
same but I see more and more this is
traditional ones that are not focused on
blockchain have steel blockchain related
companies in their portfolio and they
start to perform they start to have
exits acquisitions so they tend to prove
themselves as very valuable businesses
yeah so it's kind of like if they see
success in the investments they've
already made they'll get more excited
yeah and a poor pygmy since yeah
especially those that are now that have
invested in ripple on in coinbase
and now they became giant companies
obviously they they tend to be those
that can attract more LPS and more
investments the same with venture
capital and early-stage startups
you mentioned ripple has anybody bought
a house or property with XRP yes we had
a number of sellers listing in Xer P in
2018 but then we didn't have any sales
yeah I know I think he actually
retweeted one of those listings but at
that point the majority of people felt
that they had to hold and wait the
market to recover which never happened
yeah till now we'll see what happens
absolutely what um what's the one lesson
that you've learned building provi like
right now what's the one big takeaway
that you have so far that maybe when you
went into building the business you
didn't know or think about but now
you're like oh this is what I've learned
as a founder right yeah of course
blockchain space oh just company
building probably be ready to learn
every single week like the very often we
would discover something like hey that's
the path to go we would stick to it for
two three four months and then we
realize oh no that's a mistake so every
single week to be learning reading and
asking successful people in your field
that that have already proved for their
mentorship that was very because we did
a lot of mistakes obviously it's every
startup we did many many successes we
did all those historical transactions we
proved to the world that blockchain can
work for a real industry for real case
but just never stop learning and there
are so
many amazing books yeah I'm just asking
on Twitter like following you and see
what uh what articles people are reading
and like it this is helpful as well it's
one of my favorite things I do because
people actually find really high quality
articles yeah I tweeted it I don't know
one Saturday and tweeted it again and I
generally was interests like what are
people you know reading so I could kind
of be lazy and just yeah send me stuff
and then it was so valuable that I just
kept doing it yeah routine right yeah is
amazing yeah I can't believe all these
smart people are actually sending me
stuff to read but what um okay so being
willing to learn something new every
week do you do anything from like a
habit standpoint that you do
intentionally before learning yeah yeah
we just discuss it now with your
colleague that Joe just sit in the
corner has got a new desk [ __ ] ballin
over in the corner me with your
fantastic metrics that you're doing so
great with the podcast like don't tell
anybody that we have 10 million
downloads a month don't share that I
wish you guys could see Joe's face Joe's
bright red and he's dying laughing
twelve million downloads a month alright
go ahead
that's a great asset actually I think
you you guys are great team yeah back to
routine though Joe just trying to sell
ads it's alright so great team yeah
absolutely great team Congrats on that
and your previous podcast was fantastic
as well this book oh come on we're
recording this right after we just
recorded with kamal rava khan the author
of love yourself like your life depends
on it
yeah yeah exactly good pretty good like
those kind of books right absolutely and
this one I got into my schedule of
learnings a lot of business books okay
and a lot of psychological books on how
to be more effect
and productive and how to make my family
especially my daughter teenage daughter
how to communicate with her better and
more effective away because I can learn
a lot from experiencing the daily life
but sometimes you just read a book and
know how to deal with the specific
situation so my habit is whenever I go
to gym I have this one hour to listen to
a podcast and I have this queue of those
items that I want to hear as well as
when I go to massage which I also have a
routine also I have a podcast and it's a
I consider those hours is like work
hours because i learning for something
something specific I need in my business
today so during the day it's always
something specific I need to learn today
to make my company better what's the
best business book you've recently read
well they're a requisition oh this one I
love from impossible to inevitable by
Aaron Ross and James Jason Lemkin it's
unsigned possible to inevitable yes okay
or the book they aaron ross published
previously it's a Bible for b2b sales
predictive revenue yeah these are book
the phenomenal of for b2b sales and for
sales in general how to practically do
it how to build the team or how to
rebuild restructure some tactics then I
really love the book negotiate and
negotiate by Chris Fox by the FBI how to
negotiate yeah but someone's never split
the difference yeah Chris Voss the
former FBI negotiation yes that's great
that was also fantastic than the CEO
within a recent one by a CEO coach again
very practical on how to be an effective
SEO how to build okrs KPI is how to
score your team yourself yes so those
items are very very helpful
what
the psychological books yeah the one I
recently loved his the courage to be
disliked than the non-violence
communication so nonviolent
communication and the courage to be
disliked yeah yeah those are I really
like normally like those motivational
speakers like Tony Robbins and so on
they don't very much relate to me
because they empower you to act execute
and go into something and I have an
opposite problem I have tons of ideas
and make somebody tell you stop slow
down stop focus on the one thing so just
one thing at a time if you don't want to
pay Tony Robbins $20,000 to tell you to
go act you could pay me $20,000 I'll
tell you stop and then what uh what is
it like raising your daughter who you
said is a teenage daughter yeah in
today's society with tick-tock Instagram
Twitter I don't tinder yeah other things
yeah like what is that like it as a
parent it's tough it's always
negotiating and this book never split
the difference Cal negotiated with her
over yes she's 13 she's 30 and she has
never been into Instagram social media
chest yeah but I feel she's turning into
that and she's very much into iPad
watching YouTube videos till now they
were more like okay doing some stuff
crafts so I was kind of ok it's not that
bad but then very often she would not do
her routine stuff she's really great in
homework when we moved to the US she was
actually very self independent 9 years
old but she would go to the school all
alone she would wake up herself she
would make pasture for herself so we
just had to survive and be self
efficient because I couldn't afford
nannies or something like that and but
then now this iPad and always being on
screen it's very very hard what does she
watch on YouTube now I wish it was just
watching your podcast podcast gets
50,000 downloads a day on YouTube - no
worries yeah I'm trying to get her into
crypto we're talking very often about
Bitcoin she knows that you can buy a
house with the talk and that stuff
already but she's just watching some
teenage series plus like the announcer
stuff and doing slime so also those
childish stuff like toys and wrapping
and then what where yeah it's crazy to
me I obviously don't have any kids
although pointer would tell you I am a
kid but the rise of the devices the
connected devices the social media etc
yeah I remember as a kid like my mom and
dad had a pretty good idea what I was
doing right like I see what you're
watching on television I know what video
games you're playing like like the
things that were going into my head the
content they pretty much knew yeah I
feel like parents don't know that it
yeah harder time knowing what their kids
are doing which could be good or bad
right look me got a kid you know wants
to learn yeah just need to know that
they have borders because sometimes with
internet they feel they can do whatever
they want but well they can't there are
many apps with like parent control but
it's an additional work for a parent
okay you have again those abs you have
to control see what's going on but I
agree with you and just paying attention
look what what they're excited about
that helps to understand where their
minds are into but here our childhood
was easy and we had like you know the TV
channel with a program you have 15
minutes cartoons
well the the conspiracy theorist would
say that the state was programming
people right there I tell you what
you're gonna watch your schedule
absolutely and then you're bored between
those this time in our childhood we were
very bored what to do in between so we
were very creative and live in nature
going exploring what's happening outside
it's not go outside come on they if they
only think they know about the forest is
they saw it on their iPad since I got a
23 year old brother who was in New York
City no joke for two weeks doing an
intern she was two weeks into his summer
internship this was two years ago and we
had to go to st. Louis
my brother was getting married I'm not
him but another way and so when we get
there the entire like bridal party
whatever went golfing that all the guys
and we're out on the golf course and I
hear my 23 year old brother who's been
in New York City for legitimately two
weeks hit everyone with man so great to
see like trees I think that's my main
challenge because I love to to rest in
nature going parts and hikes and it's
very hard to get out my family from the
house and and get do that and it's very
hard for me to actually make her laugh
nature and explore like yeah but we made
it there's a habit now so she knows it
she just has to do it because it's a
family tradition
[Laughter]
it's very tradition all right so before
I get into rapid-fire questions I feel
like for people to be a user of proppy
they've got to understand real estate
and most people will do that on their
own right they'll figure out how to
learn about reals today I want to buy
property whatever but one of the things
that strikes me is I've got to know
about other countries real estate right
so I don't I understand the US for you
know New York City or San Francisco
whatever I can find that stuff out I
could talk to people who live there
whatever
how do you suggest people learn about
other countries real estate markets so
Ukraine Bulgaria whatever if I don't go
there how to actually get a good sense
for what's going on in that market I
think that that what will happen in 20
years with prop II or with another
competitor this what will happen with
property come on the the world will will
come to a one platform that they have
trust to it like an Amazon we have the
tries that the good will be delivered
then there will be one platform where
you will be able to to trust that the
value of a certain property in Bulgaria
or London is the one that should be and
the property is actually physically
there because what happens in other
countries they don't have MLS systems
they don't have National Association of
Realtors at all and there is just many
many frauds agents very often there are
fraudulent they are not licensed so
there are a lot of scams happening and
you would want you wouldn't want to risk
and buy property of this way so now you
know okay maybe I want to buy property
in Sofia for like I don't know thirty
thousand dollars which is nothing but
it's it will appreciate potentially and
then you have to go there you know you
have to invest time or with a platform
in the future you just trust the system
you would read what's going on with the
country with economical and political
situation you will trust evaluation
because it will be based on data yeah so
this is how I envision that the world
will be more in real estate will be more
open transparent and maybe even a little
bit homogenic because right now we have
so many differences but maybe at some
point we'll actually will come to a more
homogeneous market yeah it's pretty
crazy to think about how much real
estate has changed yet how fragmented
the knowledge is yeah and the process
very full of frictions yeah what do you
think the most important company in
crypto is other than proppy
encrypter company not protocol you get
neighbor protocol well I'm the believer
in Bitcoin and great answer Bitcoin
standard right I just respect all the
teams that are working on the protocols
I'll grant near aetherium we're
developing a theorem so we see a lot of
negative parts as well but I think I
mean the main thing now is to have the
real adoption this is what we are aiming
to have those enterprise and we have the
support of US institutional partners
already then when we provide the value
when we see finally that blockchain
brings the trust and change to the
industry like real estate then we need
all those protocols the underlying
technology first we have a layer in the
second layer and so it's amazing that
those teams are working on developing
them even though still there are no real
volume happening in those networks makes
sense what uh what's the one regulation
or law that you would change or improve
if you could of course you know this one
allow us innovators finally work and
innovate yeah so the securities laws and
just revamp them yeah yeah I suppose it
from 30s finally like make it to to our
century and yeah rewrite them
what about aliens believer non-believer
there is something there you think so
yeah I like you know why is I saw
something and unbelievable in my
childhood and I don't know what was that
in Russia yeah would you see something
happening in the sky but I I'm not sure
what was that what like it was like
lights or like a lot of lights different
colors yeah there were some speculations
that they were some experiments with
some rockets
nearby in the near city but I was born
in a nuclear power plant serving city so
we were only 25,000 people in the city
all engineers I and it's a small town to
see such a thing
random thing yeah but I don't know about
the aliens
maybe not aliens but there is something
there in the universe oh there's
definitely aliens come on the just so I
can put it on the record I read
yesterday that there's a star that is
close to the Sun and previously that
star there was a planet revolving around
it right that's been known for since
2016 big deal
there is now speculation and
confirmation there's a second planet
revolving around that star and so I
don't know what that means yeah it's in
like the habitable or habitable area
right that's it that word really funny
that's for habitable a type planet yeah
second one all revolving around the star
and so of course I tweet it right good
you know I basically have only two types
of friends on the internet people who
like crypto are people who like aliens
and immediately people start tweeting
back at me that it's four light years
away I don't even know what that means
that's for [ __ ] yeah right and they
still think that four light years away
could be a planet in which life could
exist oh I can't get to it but we can
somehow see it I guess yeah yeah this is
scary to me when you were in school
Russia how many planets do they tell you
there were in America they told us nine
they tell you guys nine or tell you more
yeah in the Sun system yeah yeah yeah
and now suddenly they're over a thousand
yeah I don't know where the other yeah
nine hundred ninety one of
came from but but it's pretty crazy to
think about in terms of you know you're
dealing with space and property here on
earth yeah yeah whole universe there
were such a small planet but also it's
fascinating how we're built as humans
how our system is self-sufficient we
have this intelligence we're building
the artificial intelligence yeah I see
some people on the internet that are
question you have for me to to wrap this
up
the one question I would have is what
what is the kind of a founder you
believe in to succeed like it generally
simple they don't give up that's it I'm
a big believer that building a company
is really [ __ ] hard and if you want
to put yourself through that pain you
have to have one very important quality
and it's that you will literally take
every punch right on the chin like you
don't care you're not gonna give up and
if you can have that mentality you got a
shot not guaranteed to succeed which
you're at least in Afghanistan where you
can be successful and you gotta have a
lot of things go right you gotta find
the right people gotta build the right
product and all that cuffs gotta happen
yeah but if you don't have that quality
you're dead in the water there's no way
you can build a company how do you
estimate evaluate one founder if they
have that quality or not I don't know if
you can necessarily evaluate it as much
as you're looking for other things in
their life that they've gone through
that are hard that they didn't give up
on right and so like this guy this
belief I call it the warrior theory I've
never actually shared this before so
warrior theory is basically if you take
somebody who joins a warrior culture
whether it's you know developed nations
army or some kind of you know crazy wild
sophisticated thing warrior theory is
that if you put a warrior in that
situation whether it's their first day
or their last day they are predisposed
to being successful but the difference
between the person who is their first
day versus the last day is the warrior
who it's their last heir they've been
through a lot
they're just they're literally war
hardened right they've been through it
like yeah like they have mental armor
they are ready to handle anything
because they have seen themselves
perform over and over and over again in
combat yeah yeah the person who is their
first day they believe that they have it
mm-hmm but they never proven it to
themselves
yeah and so that doesn't mean hey you
gotta go start a bunch of companies or
anything that it just means somebody
who's been through a lot of hard things
in their life immediately is better
position to handle the next hard thing
because they themselves know I bet do a
lot of [ __ ] yeah and so I think that
that's something that yeah and I
normally born as a warrior or you can
educate yourself I think that uh people
who are not warriors
are just warriors that haven't been
trained yet yeah meaning that it's all
mindset yeah right it's like it sounds
stupid and super cliche whatever but in
the end of the day it's not what happens
to you it's what you do about it
right and so like entrepreneurs are
better than anybody like there's the
[ __ ] entrepreneurs deal with on a daily
basis people that don't go through it
have no clue you know basically melted
down to talk right okay no press came
out look we're so great oh wait
somebody on Twitter screaming at us
because you know they lost their login
or whatever oh we just got nominated for
an award you know okay it's lunchtime so
it's just like this crazy up and down
all day long and it's kind of getting it
comfortable yeah yeah for that and what
are their like three tips sure for those
that are not waking up
Warriors but would love to be go do some
hard [ __ ] there's no there's no three
it's just one tip just go do hard [ __ ]
yeah right and that's different for
everybody right some people they need to
do physically hard stuff right go work
out go on a hike you know all kinds of
that kind of stuff
there's other people who need to put
themselves in mentally hard positions
meaning that they're very comfortable
and they don't ever step out of that
comfort zone and so therefore they get
to go into podcast if you're scared of
doing a podcast you should go do a
podcast yeah if you're scared of you
know [ __ ] walking in Grand Central
because you're claustrophobic there's a
people just go there and sit in Grand
Central for an hour right like like
whatever the thing is that you fear a
lot of times I think the best thing to
do is just do it yeah
and the over-exaggerated example is like
the parent who says hey my kid isn't how
to swim throw them in the pool ya know
I'm standing there to make sure it
doesn't drown right but like that's one
of the fastest ways to figure out the
kid to figure out like how do you paddle
yeah how do you swim so I think like
that stuff generally in life um is
important the other thing is go talk to
people who have been through it right
and so like do hard [ __ ] and then talk
to other people who've done hard [ __ ]
yeah and if you start to surround
yourself with like people with that
warrior mindset mm-hmm all of a sudden
you're just like yeah this is mine said
you're in power
yeah it's look one of the greatest
things that happened to me my wife is I
grew up in a family of five boys oh yeah
yeah I heard about that because you
can't be solved couldn't be if everyone
wanted to do something and you didn't
want to do it because you were scared or
nervous or you know it was hard or
whatever the other four not only did it
and you didn't see what felt left out
yeah but they made fun of you while they
were doing it yeah so officially I was
like alright well yeah you've been
through all kinds of stuff in your life
right like you're you're a Russian
influence or you lived in Bulgaria it
came to the US didn't really know
anybody like all of those things are
data points in a story then like people
go through hard [ __ ] in life and yeah if
they are successful in overcoming those
obstacles they're likely to keep doing
it yeah yeah that
totally agree with you it look every
immigrant does right because they've all
they've all lived it
mm-hmm and it's like Eileen and I talked
about all time it's just like there is
something about people who especially
immigrants who come to the United States
when they don't know anybody yeah and
especially from post communism country
you just are born to be resilient and if
you are already here you relegated
yourself that's a very very good sign
that you go through hardships you got
here so you're a fighter yeah and very
often yeah very often I got those
questions especially female
entrepreneurs on how how to move forward
when you don't know anybody how to move
forward if you a you have a kid so it's
not we agree with you pump here that
yeah just do the hard thing and go out
of the zone of comfort like I for
example had a fear of public speaking
before when I just moved here
I very much feared my accent the lack of
English fuel and see you see now again
I'm making the mistake but just going
there out of the zone of comfort and
then you'll become an expert in that and
even you have fans and you influence
people's life and so you start enjoying
something that you used to fear yeah
it's practice yeah exactly right like
how I always am shocked by people who
believe it you're gonna be good at
something you never practiced it
mm-hmm-hmm right I literally have never
met anybody who's just naturally like
the best at something you might be good
at it they might be predisposed to be
good at something right they might have
certain talents that make them good at
something but they're never the best you
might be the best yeah go [ __ ]
practice exactly all right I'm getting
off my soapbox working out where can
people find proper property calm proppy
they've come yeah all right what's the
Twitter handle I at proppy Inc at poppy
ink and what's your Twitter handle
that's not Natalia probably all right at
Natalia proper yeah all right thank you
so much for doing this absolutely thank
you I enjoy this very much long proppy
short all the soft people in the world
[Laughter]